"
BEN SHAPIRO.
HE'S ALSO AUTHOR OF THE NEW
BOOK, "THE AUTHORITARIAN
MOMENT."
THE PRESIDENT IS SET TO HELP HIS
STRATEGY GETS MORE SHOTS IN THE
ARMS OF AMERICANS AS THE DELTA
VARIANT SPREADS AND CASES ARE ON
THE RISE.
THE DAY THAT LED TO ITS RECENT
REVERSAL UNMASKS.
ALL THIS AS CRITICS SAY
DEMOCRATS HAVE ONLY THEMSELVES
TO BLAME FOR A VACCINE
HESITANCY.
BECAUSE OF COMMENTS LIKE THIS.
>> WE ARE NOT CHANGING THE
SCIENCE.
YOU KNOW WHAT CHANGED, CHRIS?
THE VIRUS CHANGED, AND THE
SCIENCE EVOLVED WITH THE
CHANGING VIRUS.
>> IF YOU'RE NOT VACCINATED, YOU
NOT AS SMART AS I THOUGHT YOU
WERE.
>> IT'S LIKE DRUNK DRIVERS.
YOU DON'T HAVE A RIGHT TO JUMP
DRIVE AND GO OUT AND PUT YOUR
LIFE AT RISK AND THOSE OF
EVERYONE ELSE AT RISK.
>> Emily: BEN SHAPIRO, WELCOME
BACK TO THE SHOW.
YOUR THOUGHTS ON THIS?
>> Ben: I MEAN, THE AMOUNT OF
BAD DATA THAT IS PURVEYED BY OUR
PUBLIC HEALTH EXPERTS IS
ASTONISHING.
YOU WANT TO TALK ABOUT PEOPLE
WHO HAVE UNDERMINED CONFIDENCE
IN THEIR INSTITUTION COME IF
THESE PEOPLE THEMSELVES.
ROCHELLE VALENCIA GOING ON
YESTERDAY AND SAYING THAT ONE
OUT OF
10 PEOPLE IS GOING TO GET A
BREAKTHROUGH CASE.
THE ACTUAL NUMBER IS MORE LIKE
ONE IN IN EVERY 1,000 IT'S
PEOPLE LIKE DR. FATTY SUGGESTING
THE CDC DOES NOT FLIP-FLOP ON
MASKING, AND THAT HE DOESN'T
HAVE A HARD DATA TO BACK HIS
SUPPOSITION THAT HIGHER VIRAL
LOAD AMONG THE VACCINATED IS
GOING TO LEAD TO HIGHER LEVELS
OF VIRAL TRANSMISSION.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE BEEN THINKING
THEY CAN CONTROL US AND NOT GIVE
US THE DATA.
IF YOU WANT TO, AT LEAST MAKE A
RECOMMENDATION ON POLICY, YOU
CAN'T LIVE OUT THE DATA WILL
PROVIDE NO DATA AND EXPECT
US TO FOLLOW YOUR ALL-KNOWING
GUIDANCE.
>> Emily: KENNEDY, IT'S OUR
UNDERSTANDING TOMORROW WE CAN
LOOK FORWARD TO THAT DATA BEING
RELEASED, BUT HOW WILL THAT
IMPACT AMERICANS CONTINUING
CONFUSION, TO BEN'S POINT, AND
WILL THAT REASSURE ANYONE,
FRANKLY?
>> Kennedy: IF THE CDC AND
DR. FAUCI AND EVERYONE FROM THE
WHITE HOUSE IS TELLING YOU THAT
YOU HAVE TO WEAR MASKS AND THAT
THERE IS IMMINENT DANGER FROM
THE VARIANTS, PEOPLE ARE NOT
GOING TO GET VACCINATED.
THERE'S NOTHING THEY ARE GOING
TO SAY, WHICH EITHER CLARIFIES
OR CONVINCES.
THAT'S THE ULTIMATE PROBLEM
HERE, BECAUSE THEY HAVE
FORGOTTEN WHAT THEY'RE TRYING TO
DO.
ARE THEY TRYING TO SCARE PEOPLE
OR GET PEOPLE VACCINATED?
BECAUSE AT THIS POINT NEITHER
ONE IS WORKING AND ALL THEY HAVE
DONE WITH THE BACK AND THE
CONFUSION IS CREATE MASSIVE
DISTRUST.
IT IS REALLY HARD TO GET A CLEAR
PICTURE OF WHAT'S GOING ON WITH
THE VIRUS.
EVEN THOUGH THE VIRUS IS
CHANGING, THAT IS WHAT VIRUSES
DO.
THAT DOESN'T MEAN THAT IT'S
GETTING MORE DEADLY.
THEY HAVE TO BE HONEST ABOUT
THAT.
>> Emily: AND MORGAN, BEN
BROUGHT UP A POWER GRAB,
ESSENTIALLY, BY THE DEMOCRATS.
LET'S PLAY A SHORT VIDEO OF WHAT
SENATOR TED CRUZ HAD TO SAY
ABOUT THAT.
WATCH.
>> IT'S PURE POLITICS.
YOU KNOW IT?
YESTERDAY VACCINES WORK.
TODAY THEY STILL WORK, BUT AS A
POLITICAL MATTER, THE DEMOCRATS
DECIDED THEY WANT TO CONTROL
YOUR LIVES.
MY VIEW IS SIMPLE.
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT MANDATES ON COVID.
>> Emily: MORGAN?
>> Morgan: I AGREE WITH THAT.
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL" AND
THEIR EDITORIAL LID THAT
PERFECTLY THIS MORNING.
OBVIOUSLY AGAINST FEDERAL
MANDATES, BUT TALKING ABOUT THE
FACT THAT PRIVATE EMPLOYERS DO
HAVE A RIGHT TO MAKE THOSE
DECISIONS AND DEMAND CERTAIN
THINGS OF THEIR WORKFORCE.
SO I THINK IT'S REALLY NUANCED,
BUT WHAT IS REALLY IMPORTANT IN
THIS WHOLE DISCUSSION IS WE TOOK
ALL OF LAST YEAR TO POLITICIZE
COVID.
WHAT SHOULD HAVE HAPPENED IS
SOMEBODY IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, I VOLUNTEERED
OVER THE SUMMER WORKING ON
OPERATION WARP SPEED AND ON THE
COVERT EFFORT.
EVERY
PERSON I KNOW RECEIVED THE
VACCINE, AS PART OF
OPERATION WARP SPEED.
PRESIDENT TRUMP AND HIS TEAM
MADE HEROIC EFFORTS TO GET THIS
VACCINE OUT.
WHAT HAS HAPPENED IS THE
DEMOCRATS USED MOST OF 2022
POLITICIZE COVID, TO POLITICIZE
THE VACCINE IN ORDER TO SOW
SEEDS OF DISTRESS.
NOW IN 2021 PEOPLE ARE NOT
BELIEVING EACH SIDE,
PRESIDENT BIDEN IS SPENDING MORE
TIME GOING ON AND TALKING ABOUT
VOTING RIGHTS AND INFRASTRUCTURE
LEGISLATION AS OPPOSED TO
SAYING, YOU KNOW WHAT?
PRESIDENT TRUMP DID SOMETHING
RIGHT WITH OPERATION WARP SPEED.
LET'S COME TOGETHER AND TAKE
THIS VACCINE AND DO WHAT WE NEED
TO DO TO END THIS PANDEMIC.
INSTEAD THEY CONTINUE TO TALK
DOWN TO PEOPLE WHO HAVEN'T
GOTTEN THE VACCINE AND CONTINUE
TO POLITICIZE THE PROCESS TO THE
DETRIMENT OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE.
>> Emily: RIGHT.
JULIE, MORGAN MENTIONED TALKING
DOWN TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
WE HAD SPEAKER PELOSI TALKING
DOWN TO HER COLLEAGUE,
KEVIN MCCARTHY, WHEN SHE SAID HE
WAS SUCH A FOR QUESTIONING THE
SCIENCE BEHIND RETURNING TO THE
MASK RESTRICTIONS ON
CAPITOL HILL.
THE REGULATIONS HAVE BEEN
RELEASED AND YOU CAN BE ONLY
ARRESTED BY CAPITOL POLICE IF
YOU FAIL TO COMPLY, NOT IF YOU
JUST DON'T WEAR A MASK IN THE
FIRST PLACE.
DON'T HAVE ANYTHING BETTER TO DO
AT ALL?
>> Julie: I'M SO SICK OF
HEARING DEMOCRATS TALK ON BOTH
SIDES OF THEIR MOUTHS.
AS FAR AS NANCY PELOSI IS
CONCERNED, DON'T PREACH FOLLOW
THE SCIENCE IF YOU ARE NOT
FOLLOWING WHAT YOU PREACH.
IF YOU WANT TO FOLLOW THE
SCIENCE, FOLLOW THE FACTS.
150 MILLION PEOPLE HAVE BEEN
VACCINATED, THERE HAVE BEEN ONLY
65,000 BREAKTHROUGH CASES, THOSE
WHO HAVE BEEN VACCINATED THAT
GOT THE DELTA VARIANT OR THE
ORIGINAL COVID-19.
THAT MEANS ONLY 0.04% OF
AMERICANS ARE ACTUALLY GETTING
IT.
NO VACCINE IS 100%, THAT IF YOU
WANT TO FOLLOW THE SCIENCE,
VACCINES WORK.
IF YOU'VE BEEN VACCINATED YOU
SHOULDN'T BE PUT UNDER THESE
MASK MANDATES.
AS THEY SAID FROM THE VERY
BEGINNING, IF YOU HAVE A VACCINE
YOU DON'T NEED TO WEAR A MASK.
THEY'RE DOING A 180 AND MAKING
ZERO SENSE WHEN IT COMES TO
MAKING THESE MANDATES NECESSARY
FOR THOSE OF US WHO WENT AHEAD
AND GOT THE SECOND SHOT.
>> Kennedy: EMILY, IF I COULD
POINT AT SOMETHING THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT, THEY NEED BETTER
MARKETING HERE.
JULIE IS RIGHT, THEY NEED TO BE
SKIMMING FROM THE MOUNTAINTOPS.
AND IT DOESN'T MATTER IF THEY
GIVE THE FORMER PRESIDENT
CREDIT, THEY NEED TO SAY THE
VACCINES WORK, BUT VACCINES ARE
SAFE, THEY ARE THE BEST IN THE
WORLD, AND ONE STUDY CAME OUT
RECENTLY THAT SAID THE PFIZER
VACCINE HAS BEEN INCREASING
WOMEN'S CUP SIZES.
IT'S A PHENOMENAL PIECE OF
MARKETING THAT I THINK ALL
AMERICANS COULD GET BEHIND.
>> Julie: I'M SO GLAD I DIDN'T
GET PFIZER, I DON'T NEED ANYMORE
HELP.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Emily: IMAGINE THAT ON THE
FRONT PAGES!
BEN, I COME TO YOU FOR A BIT OF
PREDICTION.
TO KENNEDY'S POINT, DO YOU SEE
ANY TYPE OF CHANGE IN THE
MARKETING MOVING FORWARD?
ANY TYPE OF COGNIZANT SHIFT BY
THE DEMOCRAT PARTY AS WE ENTER
INTO 2022, ACKNOWLEDGING THE
HIDEOUS IMPACT THEIR MESSAGING
HAS A PAT ON THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
AND LIKELY THE PERMANENT
DAMAGE IT'S DONE ON THEIR
ALREADY FRACTURED PARTY?
D.C. THEM ACKNOWLEDGING THAT AT
ALL AND MAKING CORRECTIONS
>> Ben: NOT AT ALL.
FOR THEM TO ACKNOWLEDGE THEY'VE
BOTCHED THE PUBLIC HEALTH
MESSAGE WOULD BE TO TAKE THE
BLAME FOR WHAT THEY PERCEIVED TO
BE REPUBLICAN FAILURES AND WHAT
THEY WANT TO PORTRAY AS
REPUBLICAN FAILURE.
IF YOU WANT TO INCENTIVIZE
PEOPLE GETTING VACCINE, YOU HAVE
A RESPONSIBILITY TO PREVENT YOU
FROM GETTING DISEASE.
THAT RESPONSIBILITY LIES IN
GOING AND GETTING THE VACCINE.
THEY WON'T DO THIS BECAUSE THERE
IS NO LOGICAL END POINT.
IT ALL STARTED WITH FLATTENING
THE CURVE.
WE AVOIDED IT.
SO WAIT UNTIL VACCINE IS
AVAILABLE, THEN WAIT UNTIL
EVERYBODY'S HAD A CHANCE TO GET
TH